et les douces ou piquantes l effet de
vos deux ports ou des gnons alain roy
part à la recherche de la vraie merguez
[Musique]
l'été c'est le moment parfait pour faire
griller des saucisses merguez
merguez c'est quoi pour vous c'est quoi
une vraie barrière c'est une saucisse
marocaine par exemple
qui fait avec jour devient on ça doit
être produit par produit vers ça doit de
manioc qu'est ce que vous cherchez pas
une merguez
le mariage traditionnel et fait ça fait
juste l'agneau des fois un peu de boeuf
si au québec on fait des merguez avec du
porc beaucoup ok jeudi mme allan youpi
une opa mais je vais les outils -
merguez aujourd'hui on va les soucis
meridiist puis 100 % à nyon j'ai aussi
mes périodes agneaux saucisses merguez à
la base c'est une petite saucisse dans
un boyau d'agneau manqué qu'un peu plus
petit mais à l'origine la choisissent
malien s'est fait avec lannion du mouton
à la base maintenant on peut tricher et
tout ce qui est aujourd hui de
l'histoire devant m boeuf avec du le
boeuf et l'agneau le défi le mouton
ensemble parce que ça permet d'avoir une
meilleure manière volume puis en même
temps que l'annoncé très grave que ça
permet un peu aussi à avoir une société
un peu plus loin alexandre duval est
enseignant en boucherie c'est sur ses
automatismes en un peu plus grand messe
palabres la saucisse toujours bon gros
match comme ça
casas à un bien
vous voyez que ça fait une belle une
belle texture non on le voit bien ses
fins
et voilà c'est bon du gros c'est bon
dean martin temps après
si la merguez original est faite
d'agneau et parfois de veau ou de boeuf
celles qu'on trouve en épicerie contient
souvent du boeuf et ou du porc viande
interdite dans la religion musulmane
sept produits sur dix ont le par comme
premier ingrédient plutôt comparable en
termes de teneur à se dire mais de
grands elles sont moins grâce qu une
merguez à l'agneau ses saucisses sont
assaisonnés à la saveur des merguez
comme celle de la fernande hier de trois
rivières une division de l'iemed à la
base la ferrandière et à l'humain selon
les experts au niveau des saucisses de
porc donc la saucisse en général c'est
un beau véhicule pour la saveur est on
peut s'inspirer de n'importe quelle star
ans c'est vraiment un véhicule parfait à
narguer c'est plus qu'un super populaire
ce fabricants de saucisses bien connu a
donc choisi de faire une saucisse de
porc à saveur de merguez pourquoi depuis
d'agneau dans la merde est si des
contraintes cuisine il faut faire une
ségrégation au niveau des viandes c'est
plus compliqué ça peut être plus coûteux
si c'est d'avoir la matière première
donc pour s'assurer d'avoir un prix qui
était compétitif pour ses merguez même
le boyau daigne au naturel a été
remplacé par un boyau végétal c'est des
raisons week d'efficacité en usine et
aussi de coups et sapiens vraiment toute
la famille c'est un boulot qui est plus
facile à couper on peut l'enlever
facilement en france un règlement exige
qu une merguez soit faite d'agneau elle
peut aussi contenir du boeuf mais jamais
de porc s'il y en a on doit l'appeler
saucisse de style merguez est ce qu'une
réglementation comme ceux ci au canada
qui règles qui encadrent l'appellation
merkel non en fait on ne peut pas encore
de la réglementation là dessus on voit
d'autres produits sur le marché qui sont
faites à base de porc on n'est pas les
seuls on trouve de bergues est de port
vous pensez quoi ça vous ça en général
de merguez de tours deux ports c'est pas
un vrai mariage
[Musique]
m
mohamed trad est un des co propriétaires
de la boucherie algérienne tassili une
institution à deux pas du marché jean
talon là c'était le premier magasin
arabe à montréal ici le temps tic
saucisses merguez et pousser tous les
jours en général c'est entre 200 et 300
quelques lots éléments par semaine par
semaine est ce qu'une vraie merguez plus
une fausse merguez oui il y apprit
merguez le vrai mariage ses agneaux et
vous avec toute naturelle selon mohamed
on se perd un peu quand on tente de
retracer la véritable histoire de cette
saucisse du nord de l'afrique il ya
plusieurs légendes la première légende
qui est un disque revient de le monde
arabe aux espagnols en 2e et 13e siècles
mais à la vraie histoire s'il a commencé
après le débarquement des gens dedans
alsacien on a géré non le début des
années il sait quand ça commence et avec
le manioc le mélange d'agneau et le
boeuf parce qu'on n'en gérait il n'y
avait pas de porc mais la vraie histoire
le magasin via de la gérer
c'est les aides les
lepinois qu'ils ont propagé en france
après dans le pays comme la belgique et
luxembourg et cetera et cetera
une chose est certaine le mélange des
pistes varie selon qu'elles soient
d'inspiration algérienne tunisienne ou
marocaine on y retrouve patrick à
coriandre cumin fenouil poivre de
cayenne cannelle clous de girofle sel
poivre
ici on va mettre des épices avec lannion
h et on est un petit peu on peut
attendre un petit peu le guinéen je suis
dessus et là on mélange c'est ce qui va
donner sa couleur à la merguez couleurs
typiques exact 1 le mélange beaucoup
vraiment la couleur tout ceci c'est
pisser on sait base de je pense à
lachute chorizo la typo l'attendait will
a italienne la saucisse merguez est prêt
on pourrait la pousser
[Musique]
et voilà que ça vous fait rêver le tissu
mariens prêtes à cuire
50 centimes la chaleur est bien chaude
déposez vos soucis
aux médias juste pour les tourner une
fois deux fois sera créé sont les faire
piquer sa lepi qui sont les pétitions
les pépites va devenir h
après quand qu'on facture une saucisse
t'ont fait jamais bouillir ça parce que
ça vient chercher toutes les saveurs à
l'intérieur de la saucisse toujours
mieux de faire griller du tranquillement
manger puis c'est bon teaser pas
vous amuser avec le temps je ne pourrais
pas celle là parce que c'est comme plus
tard - granuleux c'est plus moi je
trouve qu'elle est plus grave c'est plus
goûteuse celle-là et exige aussi est un
petit peu plus et moins ponctuels ou
juste heureuse que celle là vous avez
une préférence pour les merguez d'agneau
ouais c'est là je pense que c'était
celle que je commençais
à lannion
elle est la cuisson est particulièrement
réussi mais
quand le goût typique de mes rêves oui
même les autres si c'est pisser oppose
couleurs c'est vraiment bravo alexandre
merci merci beaucoup à vous c'est
lesquels qui est mieux